this week the Secret Service announced  that due to president Trump's frequent  traveling and because he has such a  large family the Secret Service will  soon run out of money to pay their  agents this is a big news story yes they  have to cover so many people under the  Trump administration that they are  almost out of money well as a result as  you can imagine many agents have been  forced to take second jobs to make ends  meet  true story yeah check it out there's a  well there's landscaping there's a lot  of more landscaping some of them are  sign-spinning there's some time spanning  ages and of course their party hosts for  adult toys you know yeah and this one's  called pinky LaRue  [Applause]  you